GREAT VISUAL EFFECTS CAN COMPLETELY
CHANGE A FILM'S EXPERIENCE.
WHEN I WAS 7, LIVING IN TAYLOR,
MICHIGAN, MY MOTHER TOOK ME
TO WATCH "TERMINATOR 2"
AT THE THEATERS.
I'M PRETTY SURE SHE DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THE MOVIE WAS ABOUT
AND TO HER, AND MY, SURPRISE
WE GOT TO SEE SOME STUFF
WE GOT TO SEE T-1000 GET HIS
HEAD BLOWN OFF
AND THEN FORMED
BACK TOGETHER.
AND ARNOLD CUT HIS ARM SKIN
TO REVEAL A ROBOT HAND
AND I JUST REMEMBER GLANCING
AT MY MOM A FEW TIMES TRYING
TO SEE IF THIS WAS OKAY FOR ME TO
WATCH, AND MY MOM PLAYING IT
COOL AS IF SHE MEANT TO
BRING ME TO THIS MOVIE
BUT MAYBE THAT'S JUST MY MEMORY.
MAYBE SHE REVELED IN THE FACT
THAT SHE GOT TO SEE A BADASS MOM
DUKE IT OUT WITH FUTURE ROBOTS
WITH HER SON IN 1991.
THE WAY THAT THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THE EXPERTISE IN VISUAL EFFECTS
HAS ADVANCED IN THE 30 YEARS
SINCE "T2" IS STAGGERING.
THEY HAVE BECOME THE KEY ELEMENT
IN MANY OF THE BIGGEST FILMS IN
CINEMA HISTORY.
AND WITH EACH YEAR, THOSE WHO
ARE THE BEST IN THE WORLD TOP
EVEN THEMSELVES, AND TAKE THE
ART TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
LIKE THIS YEAR'S NOMINEES.
"LOVE AND MONSTERS."
MATT SLOAN, GENEVIEVE CAMILLERI,
MATT EVERITT, AND BRIAN COX.
"THE MIDNIGHT SKY,"
MATTHEW KASMIR,
CHRISTOPHER LAWRENCE,
MAX SOLOMON, AND DAVID WATKINS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"MULAN,"
SEAN FADEN, ANDERS LANGLANDS,
SETH MAURY, AND STEVE INGRAM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"THE ONE AND ONLY IVAN"
NICK DAVIS, GREG FISHER, BEN JONES,
AND SANTIAGO COLOMO MARTINEZ.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"TENET," ANDREW JACKSON, DAVID LEE,
ANDREW LOCKLEY, AND SCOTT FISHER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
"TENET."
WELL, ALL MY COLLEAGUES
ARE OVERSEAS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEM,
THEY HAVE TO LET ME SPEAK,
SO THIS IS WHAT YOU GET.
IT'S AMAZING, AMAZING.
OUR VISUAL EFFECTS TEAM
ON “TENET,” WE DID SO MANY
THINGS AND THERE'S SO MANY
DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE TO THANK.
NOT JUST IN OUR OWN BUT IN,
YOU KNOW, THE ART DEPARTMENT
AND NATHAN, AND CAMERA DEPARTMENT,
HOYTE. AND OF COURSE OUR STUNT
COORDINATOR, GEORGE COTTLE, WHO’S AMAZING.
AND -- BUT IT ALL GOES BACK TO OUR
DIRECTOR, CHRISTOPHER NOLAN.
HE LEADS US ALL AND GIVES US AMAZING
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO AMAZING THINGS.
AND I’D LIKE TO THANK MY FAMILY,
MY WIFE, MY AMAZING CREW.
AND MY FATHER,
WHO WON THIS SAME AWARD.
THANK YOU.